so I took an ad in the Pennysaver and an
affluent Jewish area on Long Island the
five towns Cedarhurst this is what the
ad said it's on my desk to this day
we'll teach your dog Yiddish for fifteen
dollars that was my ad now that might
sound funny the funny part was people
started calling me they're like this
guy's funny I gotta see what's up with
this guy yeah what I did is it's for
fifteen dollars I would go if you like
Cujo I would come to your house and
resolve any issues you had for 15 bucks
that's how it started and then I said to
my parents I said you know I'm gonna
your grandparents I said I'm you know
I'm going to be America's first pet
psychologist and the first thing your
grandmother said to me we better get him
at the therapy real quick that's the
first thing she said of course